- Yeah, I heard it was Nazi G.I.
That's a real script.
- Oh, guys, guys, it's starting!
Oh, oh my God, I thought I was on base.
I was on the base here.
(laughs)
- Okay.
(upbeat bugle music)
- Uh, Minnesota, so far away.
What about you?
Where are you from?
- Well, define that.
I mean, like, where was I born
or where did I live the longest
or what place did I like the best?
- Oh, C-141 taking off, you see that?
- It's Caroline. No, Caroline.
"C", "C" as in Charlie Alpha Romeo Oscar.
No, my name is not Charlie.
"C" as in Charlie.
- That looks like a C-5 but
a C-5 is like, you know?
- Where were you born I guess?
- I was born in Guam,
but I only lived there
for like three months, so
it doesn't really count.
And I mean, then I moved
to Germany, so, um,
then I moved to Washington
state then Washington D.C.
- Oh wow, this place is
almost as nice as the O Club.
- What's the O Club?
- Oh, the um, officer's club on base.
It's kind of a big deal.
- Texas, California, Northern California,
and then Southern
California two years later
but in between that I moved to Hawaii
then we moved to Virginia.
- Yeah, so even with this job
I still have like seven years
until I can pay off my student debt.
How about you?
- Oh, I was actually on
the G.I. Bill in college.
- Then Turkey, Okinawa in
Japan, Illinois, Oklahoma.
- Oh my God, you're an
Air Force brat also?
- Yeah, oh my gosh!
We must have been at
Ramstein at the same time.
- Yeah, well I was stuck in
Patiala for like three months.
- So by the time I turned
ten we moved to New Jersey
and I was able to get my first ID card.
- I'm from Jersey.
- Oh, you're from New Jersey?
- Yeah, what part?
- Oh, we were stationed at Fort Dix.
I had so much fun at Fort Dix.
It was awesome.
It's an army base. Fort Dix.
- An army base for dicks.